alors vous connaissiez peut vincent
perez mais en fait la personne qui joue
dans le film d'ailleurs et qui a écrit
le scénario karine silla a été la
maîtresse de votre père gérard depardieu
avec qui elle a eu un enfant et c'est
peut-être pour cela qu'elle a le
personnage est tellement bien écrit vous
correspond tellement bien non non parce
qu'il n'était pas prévu pour moi au
départ alors d'air à l'époque c'est à
l'occasion de la révélation de
l'existence de ce bébé
roxane que vous étiez allait tout casser
dans le hall d'accueil du magazine voici
ce qu'il ya dix ans c'était bien ça vous
souvenez de sa hache c'est génial ah
j'ai pris un énorme standard le plus
gros qui avait gelé éclaté sur deux
vigiles un truc qui vaut cher et où je
vais sandrine bonnaire qui avait mis du
purin et du fumier
voici voilà dire qu'à l'époque c'était
il ya dix ans une sale époque pour vous
hein
c'était à la fin de la même année que
vous êtes fait choper en train de vente
de l'hérault a la garde de vos crédits
n'étaient pas en train de vendre c'est
des conneries ça va vraiment géant je
dépannais un copain parce qu'on était
tous dans la merde ça coûtait moins cher
le rotterdam donc on allait à rotterdam
en chêne acheter tout simplement parce
que je voulais pas demandé de l'argent à
qui que ce soit et surtout pas mes
parents qui savaient même pas je me
défonce n augment d'être tous vantent
all way longtemps et alors bel atout
quoi en plus dur ça vous à calmer ou ça
vous a rendu plus agressif ça m'a rendu
antisocial à
regardez sortant
c'est ça
social
frost antisociales
vous dites mon danger c'est que je n'ai
jamais eu peur de grand chose pas plus
de la drogue que de la prison les excès
je connais ouais en fait j'ai même pas
peur de la mort parce que en fait depuis
tout petit ça ma compagne tout ça c'est
des choses qui me font pas peur
elles vivent avec moi font partie de moi
je sais qu'un jeu ça fait partie de ma
vie je veux dire ça c'est une
philosophie comme c'est ma philosophie
ouais je peur de rien déjà 15 ans j'ai
eu des problèmes pour vol avec violence
ouais je suis mon premier séjour en
prison ça ne s'était pas bien je ne suis
pas très fier ouais c'est pas très cher
ouais c'est pas facile d'être le fils de
feu part dieu quand même non mais c'est
facile d'être office de personnes - que
bon c'est bon je dire j'ai eu les mêmes
difficultés que tout le monde mais sauf
que j'ai un caractère une nature qui qui
font que de ça se voit ouais vous avez
été bien élevés ou pas très bien parce
que votre père dit souvent qu'à l'époque
vous étiez il avait 20 ans c'était trois
ans avant les valseuses donc il était
encore dans un petit studio à malakoff
moi je campe je pense que mon père
devient lui-même maintenant on fait un
mur je pense qu'il faut vraiment
beaucoup de temps pour faire un homme
il faut fois près 50 ans il faut c'est
long surtout un garçon c'est vrai vous
auriez préféré être le fils de delon
belmondo non non je suis très content
d'être le fils de mon père malgré tout
c'est sous ces c malgré ce que dit ma
mère
malgré ce que peut dire ma mère que
bonds a plus ma mère c'est quelqu'un qui
politiquement c'est quand même ce que je
trouve qu'ils se rapprochent le plus de
mon vocabulaire façon de penser mais en
même temps j'ai très vite compris très
tôt vers 16 ans que je ferais jamais vue
plus politique parce qu'au départ je
voulais en faire je voulais partir faire
aller en afrique mais faire la guérilla
quoi c'est à dire piquer tous les
diamants et rendre rendre pollution à ce
qui est qui et qui
sinon quoi c'est à dire le gaz et au
pétrole et machin mais bon tout le monde
sait enfin j'espère que tout le monde
sait j'espère que tout le sel surtout
les jeunes que les hommes politiques
n'ont aucun pouvoir
ouais c'est pas très juste c'est
impensable d'imaginer zolédronique cher
noël mais vous n'avez aucun pouvoir
c'est un peu caricatural non non vous
savez très bien que vous êtes à la merci
d'un mot vous êtes à la merci d'une
phrase vous êtes à la maison un jour
sans un mot les mots ici en des gardes
et s'était regardé comment julien
ce qui s'est passé la déroute le machin
soir de conseillers vous êtes dans un
tourbillon vous êtes moins de tout vous
êtes moi finalement ce que je constate
avec monsieur khalifa puisque c'était
sale l'histoire c'est que j'ai appris à
fermer ma gueule parce que moi j'ai j'ai
jamais été d'accord vraiment avec les
choix de mon père
là sur beaucoup de choses et politiques
surtout mais considérant que l'argent
domine le monde
si monsieur cahill phares arrivent à me
prouver qu'avec sa stratégie il arrivera
à ce que sa jeunesse ne baigne pas dans
dans ces morts dont vous parlez dans
l'islamisme et puisse rêver de travail
d'espoir tout simplement rêver là je
veux dire qu'importe le discours et la
méthode revue qu'on ait l'ivresse de la
dignité livre la dignité la green it et
vous savez la dignité
ça peut aller très loin la dignité
si elles parlent de l'habilité du peuple
algérien puisqu'il s'agit de lui et vous
savez là bas ils sont très contents de
khalifa les jeunes quelques-uns oui il
s'est défait de masse et l'effet tapie
lui il a réussi là dinars et où eastwood
comment ça marche
vous savez l'algérie sein des pays les
plus jeunes du monde la moyenne d'âge
est de 23 à 25 ans ces jeunes là
aujourd'hui ils ont aucun espoir
beaucoup d'entre eux d'ailleurs face à
cet ac à cette misère
je veux voir château l'islamisme sur
lequel d'ailleurs joue avec moi ce que
je veux c'est sentir des passions quant
aux journées paris dit s'étonnant des
gens moi quand je veux savoir quelque
chose le surplace et ya une biographie
autorisée de khalifa qui est absolument
extraordinaire que je n'ai pas mais ici
dans laquelle il me dit qu'il fait
beaucoup pour la formation des jeunes
qu'est-ce qu'ils forment il forme des
pilotes d'avion vous croyez que les
jeunes les algériens sont nombreux à
subir des formations des pilotes d'avion
votre père a des vignobles ya quatre
jeunes la semaine dernière qui sont
morts de botulisme
le botulisme et c'était une maladie lié
à la pauvreté le coach et moi j'aime les
boeufs staphylocoque
en france d'accord et j'avais dans ma
chambre je risque de perdre ma jambe
j'espère que vous ne serez pas lancer
des cordes ans mais bon ne d écoute et d
écouter les bras on vient pas du tout
mais s'il me dit en france il ya des
jeux du moment qu'elle a du pognon
regarder du moment où il ya du pognon et
on pourrait en employant les mots et qui
c'est qui gouvernement c'est les états
unis d'accord bon alors à respecter que
la soirée quand je vais rentrer sur lyon
s'il ya une bonne volonté derrière moi
je m'en fous d'un mois je suis pas
cynique comme vous donc je dis je dis qu
sourit ce je vous laisse je ne me résous
pas à ce que ce soit les puissances
financières américaines ou autres qui
finance le monde est pour vous dire sur
la frange suis d'accord avec vous vous
avez attrapé une maladie nosocomiale
pour employer un terme pédant à
l'hôpital vous savez qu'il ya quand même
des enfants qui vivent dans les
banlieues
peut-être qu'il ya des jeunes mais sinon
il ya des enfants qui attrapent des
maladies qui s'appelle le saturnisme la
fin quand on vit dans des logements
insalubres
voilà donc c'est aussi la france est
aussi un pays dans lequel il ya des gens
pauvres dans lequel il ya des gens qui
vivent mal et nous devons nous battre
pour qu'ils vivent mieux c'est ça aussi
la noblesse et la police et dans lequel
j'ai l'âge c'est par les yeux comme
fanny monsieur messier ni monsieur ni
monsieur mère qui est aujourd'hui
ministre des finances moi je suis tout
simplement me dire que ma mère que vous
avez parlé trop vite c'est tout moi
j'aurais étudier le dossier avant mais
on le connaît bien le dossier qualify
avant le connaissent rien mais moi j'ai
rien vu pour l'instant je vais vous
faire oublier tout ça
mozart
tu es le kiné du requiem
ouais la première fois que guillaume
depardieu entendu ce morceau vous aviez
16 ans c'était un soir de déprime vous
ai mis cette cassette complètement par
hasard vous avez beau couple aurait ce
soir là et vous avez décidé de changer
votre vie et huit jours après avait
quitté l'école voilà l'autre chose qui a
changé votre vie c'est votre fille
louise
oui mais plus radicalement ouais parce
qu'au départ j'étais tout seul et puis
j'étais plein de rêves encore mon jeu
mais là j'ai en fait ça me change mais
je pourrais même pas l'exprimer parce
que c'est je suis complètement
c'est comme quand on vient de se prendre
un coup à la pointe du menton je suis
c'est chez moi je suis j'admire je peux
qu'admirer ça me ramène à des choses
enfin c'est bouleversant ce bel et bien
est ce que le fait d'être père
maintenant vous rend plus indulgent
envers votre père oui mais j'avais déjà
fait un peu de travail là dessus quand
même hein sinon il y aurait eu mort
d'homme